doctor horacio baja distintas
investigaciones científicas buscan poner
coto a esta pandemia de coronavirus
cuando ha sido su intervención su
participación y en ese aspecto
hola que tal gracias por la invitación
nosotros estamos desarrollando un
sistema de una terapia básicamente que
está basada en la administración de un
cóctel de anticuerpos que desarrollamos
en nuestro laboratorio estos anticuerpos
básicamente son
anticuerpos sintéticos pero son
derivados de los anticuerpos humanos y
la idea es hacer una administración
nasal o sea como lo que usa la gente
para para asma o sea un buffer que le
llaman acá y la idea es que esos
anticuerpos vayan directamente al pulmón
estos anticuerpos han sido desarrollado
contra la proteína que se llama spice
quan que es la proteína que usted el
virus para poder
internalizar sea dentro de las células
los virus no se pueden multiplicar
afuera de células vivas y necesitan
internalizarse debido a que no tienen
toda la maquinaria para reproducirse
independientemente como él tiene una
bacteria por ejemplo si hablamos de
organismos éste
microscópicos en este caso la idea es
hemos desarrollado yo les digo un cóctel
de 8 anticuerpos en realidad que se
pegan a distintas partes del espai
protein entonces el virus una vez que
entra al cuerpo en contacto con estos
anticuerpos estos anticuerpos se van a
pegar y van a evitar que entre a dentro
de la célula huésped para multiplicarse
en estos momentos ya lo hemos probado
con células que se trabajan
habitualmente contra el virus que yo
tengo acceso al nivel 3 que se usa de
alta seguridad para trabajar con el
virus y ya hemos demostrado que
efectivamente bloquea la entrada del
virus a las células
el próximo
en la próxima etapa es hacer estudios de
animales que vamos a comenzar a mediados
de enero y calculamos que para mediados
de febrero o hasta fines de febrero ya
tengamos los resultados de los animales
y eso entraría a un estudio clínico para
tratar enfermos básicamente vamos a
llegar a conclusiones perdón se vamos a
aclarar que esta investigación nos lleva
usted a cabo en la provincia de columbia
británica donde reside con especialistas
de allí si básicamente este estudio es
un estudio que ganamos de ese dinero
federal básicamente se llama así a echar
es la oficina federal que provee fondos
de investigación para salud y
básicamente el cuerpo de investigadores
s
obviamente a todas las partes desarrollo
y hay un clínico también que se va a
ocupar de la parte clínica en el momento
que los anticuerpos estén listos para
hacer de reclutar el pacientes y manejar
toda la parte de clínica digamos doctor
más en la comunidad en general existe
creo la sensación de que se cuenta aún
con muy poca información sobre el famoso
kobe 19 es esto así o hay realmente más
información por menos de parte de los
científicos que pareciera haber
no el problema es que comunicar con
comunicar información científica no es
fácil y lamentablemente estamos
inundados de información que no es
cierta que es muy difícil controlarla
porque en la velocidad que se que se
transmite esta información es exige
máxima inimaginable y obviamente que
tenemos más información que está en
documentación científica que
lamentablemente la audiencia o gente que
no está en el ámbito científico
probablemente no me entienda pero
definidamente sabemos estar hablando de
las mutaciones sabemos la parte de la
estructura del virus como ingresa cómo
se multiplica los problemas que hay y
los sistemas de diagnóstico lo que sale
digamos por medio de las noticias
obviamente es lo que se necesita hoy en
día pero toda la base científica
obviamente está disponible no es algo
que está escondido y que no se quiere
comunicar
buena parte de la atención está puesta
en este momento en las vacunas que
tienden a prevenir los contagios con el
comicio 19 y en su momento junto a su
colega a team set y usted había
manifestado cierta aprensión respecto al
desarrollo de estas vacunas ha
modificado su opinión es más optimista
actualmente bueno no no es que no es una
presión sino que en ese momento ese
artículo que publicamos estaba
relacionado a los tratamientos que había
antes entonces obviamente que evoluciona
tanto muy tan rápido que ya cambiaron
muchas cosas
en las vacunas y obviamente es
aparentemente son seguras porque
la vacuna que se autorizaron hoy en día
que esté de facer y moderna por ejemplo
se basan en una tecnología que se llama
el
rn mensajero solo para describir un poco
para la audiencia
no se inyecta el virus la gente tiene en
el pensamiento de que esto se inyecta el
virus no se inyecta el virus el virus
para cualquier virus para multiplicarse
tiene que llevar una información
genética que la usa una vez que infecta
al huésped entonces lo que hace es
infectó al huésped y toma a cargo toda
la maquinaria para producir proteína en
multiplicar otros virus porque la forma
que se multiplica y llega un momento que
esa célula explota y todos los virus
nuevos que hay salen ahora
él
en el caso de jacques otra aclaración
las células nuestras por ejemplo las
humanas o de animales cualquier célula
tiene un núcleo que se llama donde está
restringido el ácido el adn que llamamos
que es toda la información que dice qué
color de pelo tenemos qué color de ojos
como van a ser nuestras manos toda esa
información está encapsulada en ese
núcleo ahora en la biología hola hola
cien en la biología es evolución de tal
forma que el núcleo no está en contacto
con el resto de la célula es como una
cápsula dentro de la célula
ahora para producir proteínas
de la selva necesito información
genética o sea cómo se produce la
proteína lo que pasa es que del núcleo
se produce por ejemplo la célula
necesita una proteína a lo que va a
pasar es que llega la información al
núcleo y el núcleo produce el sistema
que vendría a ser el un transmisor de
esa información a la célula para
producir la proteína esa transmisión se
hace por el adn lo que hace es copiar
esa la secuencia de esa proteína que va
a ser producida después como proteína y
sale del núcleo por eso se llama
mensajero adn mensajero una vez que sale
del núcleo hay una maquinaria dentro de
la célula que lo interpreta lo entiende
empieza a producir esa proteína ahora el
adn por sí mismo el tiempo de vida media
es muy corto a veces son segundos a
veces un minuto a veces cinco minutos
entonces una vez que sale al
del núcleo se tiene que producir la
proteína y se destruye ahora en el caso
de las vacunas lo que se hace es no se
inyecta el virus lo que se inyecta es la
información para producir el espai
protein entonces cuando la célula recibe
esa información ve que hay en el adn
mensajero
obviamente captura no sabe de dónde
viene y lo que hace empezar a producir
la proteína esa proteína en algún
momento va a salir y cuando entra al
torrente sanguíneo tenemos sistemas
digamos células que van a identificar
a esta proteína yo no la conozco no me
muestra y ahí es en donde va a ser una
respuesta inmunológica para producir
anticuerpos entonces el sistema humano
sistema inmunológico no está
desarrollado de tal forma que empieza a
fabricar anticuerpos significa que son
proteínas también con una alta afinidad
o sea que se van a pegar a ese
anticuerpo a esa proteína es pipe
protein porque la quieren eliminar es lo
mismo que pasa con gente que recibe un
trasplante en el cuerpo nuestro lo
identifica como algo que es
extraño y empieza a fabricar anticuerpos
por eso la gente que tiene transplante
que bajarle la
fortalece la actividad digamos del
sistema inmunológico para que no haya
una reacción muy fuerte y pueda causar
problemas al paciente entonces una vez
que se produce estas proteínas sale de
la célula el cuerpo empieza a hacer
producir anticuerpos y no eso anticuerpo
circular en sangre dentro de una semana
esa persona está expuesta al virus
entonces el cuerpo ya reconoce eso y
esos anticuerpos se van a pegar al virus
y lo van a eliminar
por otros sistemas ahora hoy en día que
aparece aproximadamente 150
vacunas en desarrollo las que se
aprobaron ahora escuelas más avanzadas y
este las dos que como mencioné modernas
y fases esta es la misma tecnología del
adn mensajero hay otras que por ejemplo
la que va a venir después que las de
astrazéneca se basa es diferente es una
partícula viral que tiene también la
información genética que le da a conocer
al cuerpo que al cuerpo nuestro que es
la proteína que hay que fabricar en los
anticuerpos que hay que fabricar en
contra de esa proteína ahora en el caso
del adn mensajero lo bueno que es una
vez que entra a la célula empieza a
producir la proteína el sistema de la
célula y después se va a eliminar se
destruye o sea hay pero hay proteínas
adentro de la célula que lo van a
destruir muy rápido o sea que no es de
nea adn perdón no puede entrar al núcleo
sólo está restringido en la parte que se
hace en proteína se terminó y se eliminó
no quedan rastros no hay vestigios y de
mientras se produjeron las proteínas que
salen y se dan
será la producción de anticuerpos las
vacunas esta que tienen 2 dosis porque
hay que hacer lo que llama el booster el
sistema inmunológico funciona de tal
forma que en la primera semana 10 días
aparece un tipo de anticuerpos que no
duran mucho y después se tienen que
transformar en otro tipo de anticuerpo
que nos da la longevidad digamos de la
protección
el único problema que hoy en día no
sabemos porque es muy temprano solo
recordar que el desarrollo de una vacuna
puede ser entre 5 y 10 años o sea ahora
en una emergencia global y hay que
apostar a lo que venga y en este momento
básicamente no sabemos cuánto qué tiempo
la vacuna va a proveer protección ósea
ahora estamos hablando de los estos
ensayos que se hicieron ensayos clínicos
a nivel mundial 23 meses nada más nadie
sabe si en los próximos seis meses vamos
a estar con la protección después de un
año después de cinco años eso está en
investigación hay que esperar es un
proceso largo que es lo que toma
normalmente cuando uno produce una
vacuna o cualquier droga que sale al
mercado lo que pasa que ahora por la
emergencia todo sea corto y rápido
entonces
pues es que esos anticuerpos que va a
generar la vacuna van a ser por 5 meses
puede ser por un año pues por 5 años
obviamente que nadie espera que todo el
mundo que se vacune va a tenerlo el
nivel de anticuerpos como todos el mismo
nivel porque cada uno es distinto
tenemos distinto en la base de nuestro
sistema inmunológico es diferentes
crecimos en distintos lugares estuvimos
expuesto a distintos en medios
ambientales entonces eso varía pero por
lo menos ya se empezó a vacunar y bueno
vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa otra las
cosas que importante recalcar es que en
los ensayos clínicos que hizo fighter
por ejemplo se basa en 40 mil personas
si hubiese habido algún problema por
ejemplo hay una mortalidad o alguna
alergia o algún síndrome que se
desarrolló en 40.000 personas tendría
que hacer haber sido algo muy abundante
o sea que de acuerdo a las estadísticas
no se desarrolló o sea que podríamos
decir que no hay nada que puede ser
peligroso porque si uno dice bueno de
los 40 mil que se vacunaron 20.000
personas tienen un poste o sea un
síndrome posterior desarrollaron algún
problema bueno habría que pararlo pero
de 40 mil personas no hubo casos graves
o fuera de que es un dolor de cabeza
dolor de en el lugar nos inyectó no hay
un proceso que se pueda decir bueno esta
vacuna uno de los problemas que tiene
que le puede producir problemas
cardíacos en el primer mes o sea eso no
existe
o sea que si hubiese habido algo muy
grave ya hubiese aparecido
de todas maneras doctor os quería
preguntarle precisamente algo que usted
ya se refirió el hecho de que se hayan
desarrollado tan rápido estas vacunas
tiene que ver entonces con el hecho de
que son en realidad digamos entre
comillas el término que yo voy a
utilizar no es el correcto pero una es
una suerte de paliativo no son las
vacunas a las que estamos acostumbrados
que llevan mucho más tiempo desarrollar
y que tienen efectos que son mucho más
certeros
y
no estaría seguro en eso porque el la
plataforma que se usa ahora que ésta
bascula the fighter iv moderna son
plataformas nuevas no se conocía todo
este sistema en la época que sabines o
la vacuna contra la polio o cuando se
desarrollaron nuestras otras
otras vacunas por el método clásico la
gente hoy en día tiende a pensar de que
así no sabemos que nos están inyectando
no están inyectando el virus podemos
enfermarnos ese sistema es el sistema
tradicional cuando uno toma por ejemplo
un virus éste lo multiplicó había mi
gente y lo inactiva la inactivación
puede ser química o puede ser como yo
digo lo costeó lo que se llama atenuada
o sea que uno digamos diciendo en
comillas le cortamos los pies le
cortamos las piernas al virus entonces
no puede multiplicarse eso es la clásica
obviamente que no todo funciona porque
muchas vacunas que nunca se pudieron
desarrollar por otros problemas que no
son inmunogénicas como decimos como que
una vez que se inyecta en el cuerpo no
reacciona en la medida que uno esté
pero los sistemas que hay hoy en día no
es que pasaron etapas que no se
controlan o sea hay ciertas en el
proceso de la autorización de la vacuna
y ciertos hay ciertas etapas que tal vez
se dijeron bueno no es suficiente con
esto no es suficiente con otro no
tenemos que hacer tan profundo porque es
una emergencia que hay que hay que
desarrollarla y básicamente lo que se ve
o que al parecer son bastante efectiva
nuevamente no sabemos después de un año
si no va a funcionar o no después de
seis meses tal vez que en un futuro va a
ser bueno las dos
así que recibió señor son suficientes
para un año para dos años tiene que
hacerse como la vacuna contra el flu
digamos hacerse todos los años o puede
ser que digan bueno cada seis meses hay
que hacerse otro booster por los
primeros tres años y ver o sea son cosas
que no sabemos todavía ahí y bueno hay
que investigarlas hay que tener
paciencia en la lucha contra esta
pandemia ha habido avances y retrocesos
una de las principales trabas que se ha
debido enfrentar es el poder poner un
coto a la cantidad de contagios diarios
es que provoca no solamente aquí en
canadá en distintas partes del mundo por
supuesto se espera que estas vacunas
puedan ayudar a avanzar más rápidamente
en ese terreno cuál es a su entender en
este momento la principal traba que
existe para poder decir que estamos al
menos en posibilidad de incapacidad en
situación de poder derrotar al el
coronavirus
yo pienso que están los lineamientos de
generados por el salud pública
lamentablemente no siempre son
respetados por la población y eso es lo
más grave por ejemplo en nuestra
provincia en la columbia británica los
niveles son bastante bajos relacionado
al resto del país
la gente se controla mucho más por
ejemplo
escuché también que gente ahora dice si
es que vienen navidad es muy importante
para nosotros y no vamos a aceptar las
los lineamientos de la salud de salud
pública que dice aunque a no se reúnan
más de cierto número de personas traten
de hacerlo virtual o sea por mena la
computadora es entendible lo que
representa las fiestas para de fin de
año digamos crisis bajo años perdona
vida o año nuevo para para la gente pero
hay que tener en cuenta que estamos en
una emergencia global y
si fuera en mi familia que viene por
ejemplo mi padre mis abuelos que son
gente mayor que pueden estar en un grupo
de riesgo yo no tomaría la
responsabilidad de que vengan se
infecten tengan la enfermedad y pase lo
peor o sea yo eso no lo podría cargar
entonces yo estoy diciendo últimamente
si este año no pueden celebrar navidad
en familia no se celebra es una
emergencia global y hay que ser estricto
se ven que los números en muchos países
empezó terriblemente alto nuevamente
pronto en europa ustedes sabrán toda la
situación mundial y es porque la gente
no acata la información de salud pública
o no usa máscara o se juntan grupos en
una alguna reunión o fiestas que no
están permitidas porque una vez que uno
emite la los lineamientos que hay que en
forzarlos también y lamentablemente no
hay no se puede con toda la población y
hay casos que pasa que es el de uno y
después de una semana a que empezó con
la enfermedad cal enfermedad ya forma
visitar al abuelo que está internado en
un
un geriátrico y bueno lamentablemente
pasa lo peor porque la gente no acató o
no el respeto digamos en ese momento la
hace los lineamientos de salud pública
por último doctor sí bien entendido
entonces usted y su equipo están
trabajando sobre un cóctel que lo que
hace es desactivar la proteína que se
encuentra sobre la superficie de el
virus cuando cree que los ensayos
finales estarán ya para ser efectuados y
que podrá tenerse entonces una visión
más concreta del resultado final de su
investigación
antes que nada quiero aclarar no es una
vacuna nuestro a phil activo es un
tratamiento para gente que está enferma
en los anticuerpos nuestros se van a
pegar al virus y no lo van a dejar
entrar así como lo afirmó como dije
nosotros estamos calculando mediados de
enero comenzamos con estudios de
animales cuando se hace el estudio de
animales hay que hacer ensayos previos
como por ejemplo sin el virus y no
o sea proveer los anticuerpos y ver si
son tóxicos para el animal si tiene
alguna alergia si genera fiebre hay
muchos parámetros que hay que tener en
cuenta y después de eso se pasa con la
infección con el virus o se hace se le
administra el virus alan al animal y se
provee los anticuerpos y se ve que el
resultado sale y nosotros calculamos
para dar el tiempo extra digamos para
finales de febrero que se va a estar
todo listo pero ya tenían los resultados
preliminar alrededor del 20 de febrero
que es la idea ya podríamos empezar a
aplicar para lo que se llaman los
ensayos clínicos que también hay hay que
hacer formularios de ética de cómo se va
a ser el estudio que son requerimientos
de salud pública obviamente para hacer
cualquier ensayo clínico pero nosotros
calculamos
si es que pensamos que todo funciona con
todo el papelerío básicamente calculamos
que en algún momento en marzo
probablemente empecemos con los ensayos
clínicos que va a ser un grupo de
aumento no podemos hacer ensayos grandes
porque no hay no tenemos los medios
obviamente porque son fondos de
investigación no son fondos de
desarrollo de drogas que son muy
costosos y la idea obviamente va a ser
una comunicación con compañía
farmacéutico con el mismo gobierno de
canadá para ver cómo podemos este salir
a flote con la producción de estos
anticuerpos y la administración doctor
horacio baje estaremos atentos a esos
resultados y por el momento muchas
gracias por esta entrevista con radio
que nos da internacional muchísimas
gracias por la invitación